l tutti ragazzi e prevenute messo video
sono fa vj eccola è un sole che gira nel
caso non avesse notato se ne frega un
cazzo fate vi partire cosa sembra la
mucca di mucca e pollo uguale cazzo
mentre lui cari capello tutti ragazzi
volete le solite sono stati j oggi
stiamo su rampe che questo gioco dove
c'è un caricamento e basta cioè per
niente è un gioco che consiste nel
guardare la schermata del caricamento
che caricava perfetto ci ha messo un
anno e mezzo mai partito non ho capito
neanche bene che diavolo stia questa
roba vera ci prova la cantante è
bellissimo
cosa faccio carico arrivi o mio dio o
medierò ho vinto alla chiave la chiave
cosa faccio cosa devo fare aiuto devo
saltare alla print e ragazzi un gioco
dove di saltare su che cosa vuoi che
cazzo due in casinò vero ragazze che
devo salire le scale saltare sulle cose
la [ __ ] trai ma cos'è il bancomat
ci sono cose che non si possono aprire
per tutto il resto c'è mastercard un
precetto madre dipende dai punti di
vista posso andare su sti cosi a caso
c'è possa finire livello d'acqua sopra
giusto [ __ ] c'ero quasi perfetto
perfetto no mi scusi signora non volevo
romperle davanzale mi perdoni che
scavalca i palazzi cioè non le uso le
porte fantastico ok posso farmi mai
battere da uno che si chiama zintan get
fai schifo
grazie ragazzi finito il tutorial durato
un minuto foto e sega tanto io so
giocare lui mi sembra una sottospecie di
clark kent po betori tanto se notate
come cammina col culo è un qualcosa di
maestoso quindi devo darmi una volta
prese tutte devo tornare qui giusto
previamente ragazzi è la storia di un
superman che ruba le monete quindi è un
superman o nei graber e se voglio perdo
le monete meraviglioso diciamo di merda
io per salire ragazzi non uso le scale
io mi arrampico sulle finestre 62 63 64
porca [ __ ] 65enne senso di ok cazzo mi
chiama salvato il cornicione riuscirò
mai a finire sul livello perché non
riesco a scalare l'edificio porca eva ce
l'ho fatta morgan che è un incrocio tra
orgasmo am e morgan ha posto possiamo
fare quello dopo
ma perché sono su dei grattacieli in qua
ci sono solo 19 da trovare a questo ep
incassato un livello anche io sono
incazzato se ci fate caso veloce veloce
grappa tutto sto facendo che non ho
capito che questo non ho ancora capito
dove sti dove stiamo andando di preciso
ma ci stanno o paese pieno di monete
pieno di monete veloce veloce racz è
veloce che non te le darà vanko tua
madre per prendere il gelato veloce
minchia che culo forrest gump prendi i
miei soldi o un fazzoletto ma va bene
uguale me ne mancano 10 di monete tanto
io so che morirò prima o dio ne manca
una dove è l'ultima a nola verga dove
cazzo è l'ultima no fermi cosa stai
facendo
ma sei scemo ma come meno ecco la caccia
lo lasciate indietro
mi chiamo muoio tanto così è finito giù
è col finale
quattro i voli su non è possibile è
troppo non ho la vera gara non si arrivò
cazzo lo so già che non ci arrivo o
ragazze non ci arriva mi girano le palle
troppo
[ __ ]
ci ho messo quattro minuti ce n'è uno
che l'ha fatto in 52 secondi quanto
posso odiare i giochi che vi mettono in
ansia di quelle che una donna ma ancora
all'esame di maturità o dio c'è anche il
personaggio di andrea diprè fantastico
sì speriamo che questa sia più semplice
sono 10 dei chase perché c'è scritto
[ __ ] sul sul cosi detto è la madonna
madonna quanto incassato quanto
deficiente cazzo
manca una boa vinto tutto nel traguardo
scusata cioè dove stai
ecco e vabbè il ragazzo era mica in cu
landia vabbè non importa ragazzi di
importante che arrivino che culo ok ma
posso andare sul palazzo questo quasi
vero perfetto film che se devo fare
spider man già è difficile fare superman
visto gol culone figura di spider man
lo zio bravo bravo oddio perfetto mi è
preso un soffio al cuore per un attimo
sto capendo più cazzo vabbè ragazzi meno
male che ho e orgasmo morgan già
arrivato in ventitre secondi perché io
non ce l'ho proprio fatta a malapena
l'ho fatto in 4 minuti e mezzo come ha
fatto a farlo in ventitre secondi è
impossibile o sono io che faccio
veramente schifo oppure dio mio come
devo solo trovare una ragazzi fantastico
tra l'altro ragazzi ho notato adesso che
il personaggio già un coltello
conficcato nella testa a carissimo
ecco la sporca merda che l'aveva vista
lo vado da quest'anno semplice michele o
che aspetta di questo passo battere
record
fermi tutti il record e 9 secondi anche
ora morgan scena messi nove fermi che ci
provai bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
affanculo morgan 9 secondi 10 partner
thatcher quasi da emi che era un record
incredibile è riuscito a sbloccarmi
l'altra parte che bello c'è la terra
giusto prendete gli interessi può finire
in 24 secondi non so quanto non ho idea
di quanto io ci possa mettere ma
proviamo oggetti che si sta roba
oddio ma son bagnata miglia bellissimo
a deve infilare i tappi ok ok grazia
posso caricarci anche il telefono
effetto ok perfetto 16
minchia ho fatto più veloce di così
impossibile o sbloccato cappello
orribile bellissimo il nome del cappello
più bello del cappello stesso tanto so
che morgan mi ha battuto è lo sapevo
orgasmo di merda sono tra i feriti c'è
il mondo ad aver fatto sto punteggio
riga mi chiamo in pvc gis perché sigis
sta per sigismondo e ip vista per i
piselli volanti non fate domande ragazzi
facciamo l'ultimo tanto so che non
riuscire a battere morgan ma provo a
dare il meglio di me vedere che cazzo
succede 20 secondi ragazzi per battere
il record del mondo che non ce la farò
mai provate vai vai vai che si carico ma
che se carico maglia 6 carico madonna
che bordello ok
e vabbè tanto sono dice 20 [ __ ]
non sono entrati in classifica per un
secondo a vela e pazienza però casuale
ho finito di file che è un gioco
stranissimo interi e non so perché l'ho
fatto però mi aveva attirato il culone
del protagonista sinceramente niente
ragazzi spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto è stato strano lo ammetto cosa
sono se vi è piaciuto se l'argomento è
un mi piace anche la pagina di facebook
che come me voglio tornare iscrizione
sono serviti siano ci davano proseguito
ei ragazzi